hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica I've got
a problem I'm about to die he my water
content is too far low and I don't know
if I'm gonna be able to recover it I
might be able to recover it if I can get
a fish that's gonna be able to give me
some goddamn water preferably like a
bladder fish or maybe one of these bad
boys
bladder fish come here I bet if I eat
you I get some water no no I'm gonna die
I'm dying I'm dying I'm gonna hear it
here's how I died I died here I'm dead
I'm dead now this is me being dead dead
dis me ha ha ha ha well there were
[ __ ] god dammit at least gah [ __ ] I
lost a whole hell of a lot I lost more
than I was willing to lose but that's ok
least I still have my eye on crystals
and at least I'm back in my base so you
know you can kind of look at the
positive things in life I'm gonna let
red Eichorn take care of the ion
crystals and I'm gonna keep this
disinfected water on me at all times and
hopefully not die but welcome back I
have to do a thing I have to build some
more lockers
ok so I have 3 new names on the locker
the first being Dawn Leia Nguyen who
said finally you got the prawn suit no
hacks which I've been very proud of I've
done nothing to cheat in this game
period and it has been such an enjoyable
experience except for all the dying and
being terrified of the ocean parts that
guy has sucked but that's okay next up
is Keith Sealy who wanted to know
exactly how many times I blew up my
seamoth and the answer is zero
I did not none it's the same seamoth
that I built I wouldn't want to have go
out and build another one because I'm
lazy and I hope to keep everything that
I have intact and then char who had some
really interesting insight into the lore
of this so apparently we all know about
the do Gossie but ten years ago is when
the de Gossie mysteriously vanished
while trying to make a slingshot
maneuver
around this very planet which is exactly
what the Aurora
was trying to do as well and apparently
the aliens don't know the difference
between a slingshot maneuver and someone
trying to land on the planet and
supposedly if you take a look at your
hands and I don't know if these are
going to be able to show the hands but
if you take a look at your hands
anything that gets on this planet is
infected by a disease like literally
infected by a disease that is only on
this planet and that is why the planet
is quarantine it's not something that's
so profound is like the curse of
existence literally that gun is there to
be like hey don't [ __ ] come on this
planet it is under quarantine you will
die this is for your own good it's
apparently something that kills
absolutely everything it touches but
that doesn't explain why the biology of
this planet is so vibrant
that's what char says so I don't know if
that's a hundred percent accurate it
sounds accurate but it's just
fascinating to think that there's such a
virulence strain of disease that these
aliens are doing everything they can to
make sure it never leaves so anyway that
is as far as I go on the lore of it next
up I have to make this prawn suit and in
order to be able to do that I need lumen
amok side
I need plasteel aerogel and lubricant
now the only complicated thing is the
plasteel but that's actually not too bad
because even though I got robbed in my
lithium I have one diamond in there
that's nice to know I'm pretty sure I
have enough to be able to make more
plasteel so plasteel is just a
combination of a titanium ingot and
lithium so I just need a buttload of
titanium and then lithium and then I
need spore sack and I need aluminum
oxide crystals now aluminum oxide
crystals I believe I'm not 100% sure on
this one but I'm pretty sure that they
are down south and by down south I mean
really down south like really down south
so what I'm gonna do is I'm going to put
away anything that I absolutely don't
need I need
I might keep composter because if you're
freaking adorable not to put that there
can my pron suit poster there and oh
that's nice
I'd like that I got decorations I'm a
decorator I'm one that likes keepsakes
because I'm so freaking alone and I
desperately click onto anything that's
gonna keep me in contact with the human
species I'm gonna die maybe I'm not oh
what a cute kid so what I need is I need
to go down into the depths god damn it
my CMOS is all the way over [ __ ]
there god damn it where's my goddamn c
glide urban streets yeah you got my seat
like give me my goddamn C glide we're
gonna [ __ ] glide here I know
god dammit I die come on yeah
alright go gotta go pick up my seamoth
from the impound lot but then I'm gonna
go get aluminum oxide crystals and then
I should be able to make the prawn suit
right away
and thankfully there's a whole buttload
of things to mine out by the aurora so
it wasn't too bad of an idea to keep my
base there but eventually i'll move it
out to get closer to other places that i
need to go okay we got my seamoth i'm
gonna hit back to base i'm gonna drop
off my c glide and hopefully we're gonna
be able to explore the deepest darkest
regions that we can at this moment we
can only go 300 meters down but that's
enough to be able to explore the purple
caves and maybe find that other
underwater base because there is an
underwater base down somewhere in that
area I just don't know if it's in those
caves right there they may be in another
one but I'm not well-versed in the new
geology of this planet but we'll get
there soon enough it's all about
learning and exploring and having fun as
we do it right and not dying
hopefully not dying it's gonna be good
Maya might as well grab this you know
there's all this [ __ ] titanium here
because I'm gonna need a whole bunch of
you before I get back eventually so I
might as well drop all this scrap off
it did be able to build what I need to
build it it's gonna drop some [ __ ] off
Diablo
I'm gonna put you back in urban stretch
I should be everything that I need on
the way again don't hit my base you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm on the road again
don't go nowhere no [ __ ] I'm gonna hit
you ugh
caboose key Oh also I want to hit up my
uh I want to hit up the life pot real
quick because apparently there are
messages waiting for me in that life pod
now I don't know what these messages are
gonna say and I don't know what they're
gonna mean for me but they probably are
gonna be interesting
oh good I think they finally made the
station air alright up we go hello this
is la fête in life pod 17 I survived the
impact but there's something outside the
hatch trying to get in if anyone's still
out there my coordinates are attached
this message will now repeat I don't
know the Fed is and I don't know where
your coordinates are let's take a gander
ok yours is oh it's over there alright
then well that's the only message that
I've got and it's pretty new so okay
I'll give it a look but I've got other
things to do I don't know what we'll be
trying to get in it could be something
big but judging by his not panic nature
I'm assuming it's something not entirely
huge unless it's just one of the bitey
things over here but given that it's new
it may have been something new that was
trying to get in I have no idea
Oh apparently I have a new message okay
they keep giving me messages when I'm
not in why can't they call when I'm
there oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] is that
always there oh hello
okay well something got in apparently
man I don't even hey hey you [ __ ]
pieces [ __ ] oh oh stop freaking out hey
hey
wrong wrong you are much faster than you
used to be holy [ __ ] those things used
to be fat like slow and docile there's
data pad in there that I want to get
okay Dave download anything else in here
hey yeah yeah I get it I get it you want
to eat me I get it everybody else does I
get it here we go lifepod made
planetfall intact approximately one hour
ago environmental instruments were
knocked offline with my face pressing of
the glass I can make
shadow shifting about water in front of
me every so often the pod is rocked by
some kind of collision I cannot tell
whether the pot is bumping up because
rocks is something out there trying to
get in
either way the hull is beginning to
buckle I can see what's left of the
Aurora from the top hatch we were
carrying anything and everything we
might need to complete the phase gate
all terrain vehicles thermal reactors
propulsion cannons I'm gonna go out
there and scavenge whatever I can find
see if I can reinforce the Life pod home
well I'm guessing that when he went
outside he found a face full of death
and now I'm about to found a face full
of death because the Sun is setting but
what is this unknown technology of still
soon oh cool that is the thing I believe
that will recycles water which is gonna
be very good I always enjoyed drinking
my own piss I always enjoy a nice
refreshing glass of yes rush sues my
soul and I see another scannable dvdp
boopadoo big dude who's getting the [ __ ]
back in my ship now holy [ __ ] we're
going away okay that's about everything
hello are you going down you're down to
the purple caves aren't you whew that's
scary hello hi my name is markiplier am
i welcome in this Wonderland of purple
hell I bet not who's got a worm in you
which one of you got a friendly worm
uh-oh every day is a new chance to
experience hell am I in the right place
for aluminum oxide conditions in this
cave may support microcosm of unique
possibly predatory life forms try to
counter unanticipated threats by
anticipating them well seems like it's
just gonna be golden and lithium which
doesn't exactly help me
stop it not worth it I'm hearing a lot
of roaring and Al and I came down here
to get away from all the roaring I don't
appreciate none bit well it seems like I
might be in the wrong place because I'm
not seeing what I knew that's a big in
that that's a big in that's a big one
cuz that's a small one that's a big boy
was that gasps oh oh yeah oh yeah I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure something
wrong on going on there
bad that that ain't right then that's
not right there's some wrong there if
there is an underwater base here man
they were [ __ ] in the head because who
would put in all my god there's an
underwater base who did this who was
[ __ ] up enough to build one down here
well moon pool moon pool moon pool mine
pal so what I'm gonna do actually I'm
going to change out this it's down here
put this on
rebreather which should help me not lose
as much oxygen as I have been it should
allow me to explore this place without
getting horribly flubber knocked here we
go scanner at the ready was it nothing
nothing roof boosting I don't want the
grouper all water filtration hell yes
stop screaming at me okay God water
filtration which is gonna be good thank
you thank you no thank you no thank you
Shh okay PDA that one hell yeah
Oh a double better for eventually when I
have friends I'll be able to have them
sleep next to me so I can watch them
when they sleep okay goodbye I'm out
here out of oxygen
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] just want to
grab this okay got that that was it I'm
out it I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out
I'm out goddamn it get the [ __ ] down
yeah I'm out I'm out baby I'm Audi Audi
Audi Audi what is that so late oh that's
my light is that my light that's my life
okay you got that [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
something happened we've been di Hey hey
what the [ __ ] what the what the fear
what the FAK witness yuck what there
theok okay everybody shut the [ __ ] up
I'm not happy with what's going on here
until you big droopy [ __ ] I hit you
something happen we've been out here for
two months now we ran out of enameled
glass hello big guy and Margaret here's
what she does she goes out to the kelp
forest armed with just the heat blade
and goes fin to fin with a pack of
stalkers no wonder she was so interested
last night - know what I've learned
about him based on my wild theories
about alien behavior she hand-fed an
alien shark she came home with a fresh
cut on her forearm
didn't say anything about it but I guess
it took a couple tries she says once
they're fed they're harmless she brought
home all the teeth we need on one hand
that is the most badass thing I've ever
heard and now I'm sitting in this
observatory watching biters tap
harmlessly at the glass on the other
hand how many of those incredible
creatures did she have to kill just to
tame one what effects are we having on
the ecosystem here Foley I had a
full-size aquarium I would kill to study
these life-forms in detail we're already
more than 200 meters below sea level you
want to go deeper Margaret we've been
here a couple months now chief look
around us I see water leaking through
the hull water outside the hatch water
above me below me we're drowning
real slow if rescue arrives whatever
shot us down is gonna do that again and
again until it's shut off you see an off
switch around here chief why would an
off switch and be any more like
be a half kilometre down it's a hunch
you're mad I'm going and I've got an
idea you two are gonna follow if you do
be mindful your authorities stopped at
sealing well I mean they're not wrong
they're actually quite right because
apparently there is a research station
even farther down below this is
fascinating to hear the story about
these people that were here from the de
Gossie which is the ship that crashed
ten years ago like 10 years I mean
obviously these people are probably long
dead because if you know if if the
elements didn't kill them then they
killed each other because obviously if
they weren't getting along and if
they're not getting along and there's no
cooperation then there's definitely not
gonna be a way that they're gonna
survive and hello where are we now
oh we're where I built the base before I
think where I used to build the base
anyway so what I need to do now is I
need to look up where the aluminium
oxide is because I have not found any
and I'm not gonna end this episode
without a prawn suit so I'm gonna find
that right and y'all I know where it is
now it's in the grand reef and so in the
grand reef is actually to the south of
here or at least in the ass-end of the
aurora I don't know if I'm going to be
able to get down far enough to get to
the grand reef because my limit is 300
meters and I can only dive so far down
and I do not have my sea glider to be
able to get some extra distance as I go
down but maybe I'll be able to go down
far enough but I'm not a hundred percent
sure I just really want that aluminium
oxide so I'll be back if I know I can
get it I'll have an answer for you
either way
ooh I think this is it is that aluminium
oxide or is that just quarters in
schools damn it take you where's your
Luminox odd weird elumen Adi where is it
taking you with me you're gonna tell me
what my entry is oh there it is okay
thank you I'm gonna take this anyway all
right so I can get aluminum oxide I
definitely want ever since can but I
just can't go that deep I'm getting
that's okay Karen I appreciate your
concern but me and my friend here whoa
whoa whoa whoa look at his shadow holy
[ __ ] that's weird okay me and my friend
here we're gonna get all the aluminum
oxide that we need and I'm pretty sure
we need at least like four more should
be safe
ooh I found the mother lode okay caboose
key caboose key oh man
it's a plethora by the the vents oh jeez
that's hot boy I'm just gonna get them
all I mean the more the merrier I'm not
really at a whoo whoo whoo ow ow ow ow
ah it's toasty ah my buns my buns okay
so I have nine that should be more than
enough I'm gonna give this one more just
because it's standing out at me
okay but the other good thing is that I
also got the recipe for the moon pool
which means that whatever base I build
next I'm not gonna do this by the Aurora
I'm just gonna there's gonna be the LAT
the prawn is gonna be the last thing I
built by the Aurora and then after that
I'm gonna build a new base and then from
there I will build a moon pool on top of
it it will probably be closer to the the
inactive lava zone entrance which will
mean that I'll have a better launching
plan to the next phase so I'm going to
take care of that but right now I also
need to get some more titanium okay so I
just need to get the lubricant and then
I need to get a spore sack of some sort
I think the spore sack was in the
crevasses here so I might be able to
find something but I just need a bunch
of this to be able to get enough Lube
Lube me up baby
lube me hard every day is a good day to
get Lube II see if I can find me a sack
I am I seeing a sack around here a nice
hefty juicy tasty sack any old sack I'll
do sorry any sack I'm not biased when it
comes to my sacks
I'll literally take anything whoo ahh
well that looks like a tasty sack and I
know I've got another one of these back
home so I think that's all I need and
then I should be able to make my pron
now what I'll be able to make after
the Prada I have no [ __ ] idea oh and
that's good all right let's make Malou
be Lulu be okay one plasteel ingot the
Sun is setting but that does matter
because I'm gonna have everything that I
need and then the mobile vehicle base
should be able to do all that and listen
oh no oh no I'm not gonna have enough
power walk
really really really oh really and then
my spotlight is taking up even more
power what a bag of dick I do I can't I
literally can't what a sack of [ __ ] oh
can I make a bioreactor cuz I got a lot
of biological material I've got half of
this stuff for a bioreactor well eat my
chode I gotta wait till day maybe if I
shine a flashlight on this it'll give me
some power ah
let there be power is it working I'm
gonna deconstruct this sack of [ __ ] cuz
it's not any good for me Little Lulu can
I have all these back thank you okay it
is now the following day and we're
starting to get power so I just need to
make the aerogel then I'll be good I've
also put another solar panel so
hopefully I'll get it a little more
power little more quickly and a little
more power to keep me warm at night and
then I'll disassemble everything and
then move it okay but now I should have
everything that I need right I got I got
absolutely everything I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure there's gonna be it
covered Oh oh god sorry Deborah Billy
Sam watch Marshall I don't know what I'm
doing
yep yes boom oh yes it is normal when
first piloting the pron suit to feel
sense of limitless power at your
fingertips professional bra operators
received weeks of training to counteract
this phenomenon you will have to try to
not let it go you're it whoa hey I
didn't even see you building good job
boys
hello the limitless power you say
captain oh yes thank you so can I mine
who punch punch pounce pounce pounce
pounce pounce pounce pounce pounce and
pouncing as hard as I can tell this is
not minding it but that fact here you
I'm going to
aren't you here you are to get pounced
he'll pounce pounce pounce hey come back
here and get beyond that wall [ __ ] a
squashed him he got squat oh no he's
alive come here and get pounced peons
peons peons [ __ ] don't run from my
Pyong cheese your [ __ ] right fine well
apparently I don't have the UH the drill
well [ __ ] well a bunch of bag of dicks I
don't have what I need for that great
wonderful I've got a prawn suit but no
upgradability whoa boy I gotta build me
a moon pool to be able to do that okay
but either way I got a mission for me in
the next episode and I know what I'm
gonna be doing the prawn suit can go
down to 900 meters that's without a
pressure compensator it can go all the
way down to 1,200 with a pressure
compensator so with that I can
technically go down as far as I need to
but I would like to be able to build
another base which is gonna take a lot
of doing but I think I can do it I just
need to build the Cyclops store all my
stuff from this base maneuver it
somewhere else and then build another
one but we'll see about that in the next
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye-bye
[Music]